l'air a été fâché même plus d'espacé des
nuages vous vous faites comment avec les
enfants on n'a pas le temps avec novion
voyage temps
un responsable adjoint du tout jaloux
d'eux qu'est ce que vous attendez
mais elle veut pas d'enfant s'ils
s'acquittent occupe de tout de sa pilule
et tout ça sur un cours d'eau
c'est à dire une petite pilule
[Musique]
quoi
j'ai grossi pauvre sujet était
magnifique mais c'est quoi ces messages
sont énormes
oui il ya une grosse heure là une tumeur
je comprends c'est un bébé un bébé
cancer
[Musique]
l'appui faire ça écoute clair je vais
m'en occuper
surtout seul votre faim n'a pu vous
accompagner elle travaille meiway toi
oui je te présente be blood
bonjour bible le salaire au bonjour quel
instinct j'ai mangé du camembert et
après pour faire passer le goût du
camembert j'ai pris du vin tué fin maman
je vois du fromage prend du fromage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du bolchoï
[Musique]
c'est moi qui vais la lutte et madame
bisson mallette d'apprendre une prothèse
d'accord qui est relié aux mamelons il
avait vu une psychologue
[Musique]